SPEAKER 1: Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE,
is Google's secured
and fully managed
Kubernetes service
that now includes
a revolutionary autopilot mode.
It allows you to build, deploy,
and run fast, reliable apps
and services.
But how do you ensure that the
infrastructure you provision
to run those services remains
reliable and available
for developers?
Today, I'm going to show you
how to manage GKE infrastructure
at scale with Cloud Operations.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
Imagine getting a
ticket like this one.
You know that a service
is having an issue,
and the service
owners are asking
you to help them
determine whether it's
being caused by the GKE
infrastructure they're
running on.
The problem is that
there's a default namespace
in every cluster in your org.
How can you possibly find
the one you're after?
Let's see how Cloud
Operations can help.
From the monitoring
overview screen,
let's click on
the GKE dashboard.
By looking at the
last six hours of data
and expanding the
alert timeline,
we can in fact
confirm that there
are no alerts in the
default namespace.
We can also confirm
that there aren't
any issues with our nodes.
Let's have a look at the
workloads in that namespace,
to see if there are
any issues there.
We can find the workload
by clicking on View All
and then searching
for the namespace
where we know it's running.
It looks like there is
a memory utilization
alert for this workload.
Let's check to see if there are
any infrastructure issues that
may be causing this.
Let's click on metrics
and select Memory
under Node Metrics.
Here, we can see that the nodes
aren't having any memory alerts
or issues.
So we can rule
out infrastructure
as a probable cause for
this particular incident,
and we can reply to
the original message,
letting them know that
memory issues are constrained
to their specific service.
Being able to take a very
limited amount of information
about a problem and
quickly determine
whether an infrastructure
issue is at fault is fantastic.
As an operator, your time
is incredibly valuable,
and being able to quickly
eliminate your infrastructure
as a culprit is great.
But what about
the service owner?
Let's have a look
at another example.
Does your inbox
look like this when
there's a problem of any kind?
This might happen if there's
an alert flood caused
by a widespread issue, or it
might happen just because there
are a lot of alerts
that might be triggered
for any number of reasons.
How can you quickly
dig through this mess
and figure out what's
actually important,
and whether your
service is impacted?
Let's see how Cloud
Operations can help.
Let's see if we can figure
out whether our service was
impacted by an
infrastructure issue.
From the monitoring
overview screen,
let's go to the GKE
dashboard and have a look
at the behavior of our
system over the last day.
When we expand the
alerts timeline,
we can see that there
are two node alerts.
Let's have a look at
the resource associated
with the alert.
We can see that we are
getting high CPU alerts.
In the metrics tab, which
can confirm elevated CPU
utilization of the node.
When we look at
container metrics,
we can see that there
are a number of services
that are running on
this particular node.
Some of them did not see
increased utilization
during interval.
However, at least
two services did
see elevated CPUs that
corresponds to elevated CPU
utilization on the node.
So we can confirm that not
only was our service impacted
by increased resource
utilization of the node,
but another service was as well.
Thanks for joining me today.
We saw how Cloud Operations
can help you quickly
isolate or eliminate
infrastructure issues
from a limited set of data.
We also saw how to
use the timeline
to quickly filter alerts to
determine whether your service
is having an issue or not.
I hope this helps you to
keep your GKE infrastructure
reliable and available.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.